تعيش الدول الآسيوية مع
تفشي فيروس كورونا منذ شهور ،
ومن أولى الدروس التي تعلمها الناس
هنا ألا نشعر بالذعر ، فنحن لا نشعر بالذعر
ولكن ربما نشعر بالإحباط قليلاً
لأنه مزعج كما ترون
هنا في سيول لا تزال الحياة  يستمر ، ولكن إذا
كنت قد بدأت للتو في مواجهة
وباء فيروس كورونا المستعد لبعض
الاضطرابات الخطيرة في جميع أنحاء آسيا ،
فقد تم إلغاء أو تغيير خدمات الكنيسة لأي حدث يتضمن تجمعات كبيرة
أو تغييره بشكل خطير
في اليابان ، على سبيل المثال ،
يلعبون لعبة البيسبول الاحترافية في
تسبب الفيروس التاجي في الملاعب الفارغة في آسيا
في أكبر تجربة في العالم للعمل من المنزل
، وأعتقد أن العمل من المنزل بالنسبة
لنا قد حقق نجاحًا كبيرًا ، وقد أثار
أسئلة بالنسبة لنا حول ما إذا كنا
بحاجة إلى مساحة المكاتب التي لدينا
موظفين حرفياً  الاتصال بهاتفياً في
العمل عن طريق التداول بالفيديو وتجنب
السفر وفي الوقت نفسه يتعين على العديد من الآباء
رعاية الأطفال في المنزل لأن مدن
مثل هونغ كونغ  أغلقت المدارس لعدة
أشهر ، لأسباب مفهومة ، هناك الكثير من
القلق في الوقت الحالي ، لذا تتحمل الحكومات
مسؤولية أن تكون شفافة في وقت مبكر
من الأزمة ، حيث
حاولت الحكومة الصينية إسكات الخبراء الذين
حاولوا دق ناقوس الخطر الذي يضر
بمصداقية الحكومة وينشر
عدم الثقة يتفق الخبراء  إن مفتاح
وقف تفشي المرض هو
السيطرة على عدوى النظافة الشخصية من قبل الأشخاص الذين
يرتدون أقنعة وأيضًا عن طريق
لف يد نظافة اليدين بمسحة من الكحول يعاني العديد من
حاملي الفيروس التاجي من أعراض خفيفة ،
لذلك من الضروري تحديد أولئك الذين يعانون من
هذا المرض المعدي عن طريق اختباره.
التشخيص المبكر والعزل المبكر والعلاج المبكر
الدعامة الأساسية لعزلتنا
ومنع هذه العدوى من
انتشار تفشي فيروس كورونا
هي ظاهرة عالمية لذلك من المحتمل
أن تشعر ببعض التأثير ولكن بغض النظر
عن الإزعاج تذكر أن
أهم شيء في المستقبل
هو  للبقاء بصحة جيدة Ivan Watson CNN Seoul ،
تسافر إلى r
ألغت القيود المفروضة على الرحلات والمخاوف المتزايدة من حدوث جائحة ، فإن الخوف من فيروس كورونا قد يكون أسوأ أزمة لصناعة السفر منذ هجمات 11 سبتمبر ، يقول الخبراء إن الصناعة قد تلقت بالفعل ضربة هائلة ، إنها مجرد بداية وجدت دراسة استقصائية لمؤسسة Kaiser Family ما هي قام ثمانية أشخاص بالفعل بتغيير خطط سفرهم بسبب مخاوف من الفيروسات ، كما حدث انخفاض حاد في السفر عبر المحيط الهادئ ليس فقط من الصين وإليها ولكن أيضًا إلى دول آسيوية أخرى يُلاحظ هذا الانخفاض في كل من السفر الترفيهي والعمل تم إلغاء العديد من المؤتمرات الكبرى بما في ذلك مؤتمر فيسبوك f8 ومعرض جنيف للسيارات ، ومن المفارقات أن معرض ITB Berlin هو المعرض التجاري الرائد لصناعة السفر نفسها ، ويقول الخبراء إن ملايين العمال قد يفقدون وظائفهم أو ينقطعون ساعاتهم إذا استمر الطلب في التضاؤل من مخاوف فيروس كورونا الذي يؤثر أيضًا على كيفية تأثير البعض. تتعامل الشركات مع بعضها مع عدم تشجيع السفر غير الضروري بالنسبة لهم  وجدت دراسة استقصائية شملت 400
شركة أجرتها رابطة سفر الأعمال العالمية
أن ما يقرب من نصف
الشركات قد ألغت أو أجلت
بعض الاجتماعات أو السفر على الأقل
لمشاهدة المستهلك ، أنا ماري مولوني ،
هذا الطريق سيكون عادةً مليئًا بالسيارات التي
تتقدم ببطء نحو
نقطة التفتيش  300 نقطة العبور الرئيسية
بين بيت لحم والقدس على
الجانب الآخر من ذلك هي إسرائيل ، لكن
الطقس ليس هو ما يبقي الناس بعيدًا ،
فالمدينة مغلقة بعد أن تم تحديد سبع حالات إصابة
بفيروس كورونا هنا
في وقت مبكر من صباح يوم الخميس على شبكة سي إن إن.
بتحد
خارج متجره لبيع الهدايا التذكارية
للسائحين سأحاول اليوم ، أخبرنا ولكن
إذا لم يكن هناك أحد سأضطر
لإغلاقه لمدة شهر عندما عدنا بعد 90
دقيقة ، كان محمد
قد حزم أمتعته وعاد إلى المنزل على الطريق الذي
يراه بينج  تم إغلاق الفندق الأيقوني المحاط بسور ،
ولم يستقبل أي ضيوف اليوم ليلة أمس ، حيث
وضعت بلدية بيت لحم هذا الفيديو على صفحتهم على
Facebook.
تم تطهير المدينة بما في ذلك
ميدان المذود القلب السياحي للمدينة يوم
الجمعة تم إغلاق كنيسة المهد التي يُنظر إليها على
أنها مسقط رأس السيد المسيح
من الباب الصغير الذي يدخل من خلاله معظم
المصلين إلى الكنيسة مغلقًا بإحكام
على الجانب الآخر من ساحة عمر
بن  وقف مسجد حديد فارغًا وكذلك
صلاة الجمعة ، أهمها إلغاء صلاة الجمعة ،
كان مصطفى البالغ من العمر 19 عامًا
واحدًا من القلائل الذين خرجوا ، وسيحدث ما
يريده الله ، لكنني لا أعتقد أن
الناس يبالغون في رد فعلهم ، يجب أن
نعتني بأنفسنا على بعد أميال قليلة  بعيدًا في
باكالا المجاورة ، وجدنا أن
الأشرطة الأمنية لا تزال خارج فندق
الملائكة مركز تفشي المرض هنا والذي
تم ربطه بمجموعة سياحية يونانية
أقامت الأسبوع الماضي ، ثبت إصابة أحدهم
بفيروس كورونا عند
عودته إلى اليونان
14 أمريكيًا بمن فيهم  تم إخبار 13 من الكنيسة الثلاثية
الدائرة في فيرهوب ألاباما الذين
وصلوا إلى المدينة في بداية الأسبوع
في جولة في الأراضي المقدسة
بأن يتصرفوا.  arantine طُلب منا
العودة إلى الفندق الذي فعلناه وقد
تم عزلنا هنا لمدة يومين
وتم اختبارنا للتو بحثًا عن الفيروس عندما
يتعلق الأمر بمسألة
ما سيحدث بعد ذلك ،
فإن الإجابة المدوية بالنسبة لنا هي أننا  فقط
لا أعرف وهذا هو الجزء الأصعب
ولكن لا نعلم أننا لا
نعرف ما الذي ستعود اختباراتنا
إليه لأننا نريد من السلطات تزويدنا
بمزيد من المعلومات ونريد معرفة
ما يجري و  نريد أن نكون قادرين
على العودة إلى المنزل في أقرب وقت ممكن ، كان
هناك رجل واحد كان سعيدًا بممارسة
عمله هو جيمي العازار الذي كان
يملأ سيارته بالغاز نعم سيدي
لا تعطيني لقطة لتغطية القمر
إليك ما تنشره  هذا
على الشاشة كاثرين ، كل هذا يشير إلى
أن كوفات 19 هو مرض حميد نسبيًا
بالنسبة لمعظم الشباب
وربما يكون مدمرًا لكبار السن
والمصابين بأمراض مزمنة ، وإن لم يكن
محفوفًا بالمخاطر كما ورد في تقرير
طبيب التباين بين ما حدث على
الأميرة الماسية  ورقم wh أوه أو
الذي يخرج من الصين ، إنه
سؤال رائع وكل ذلك يعود إلى
ما تقيسه بالفعل لما تختبره
وأنت تعلم أن الاقتصاديين يفعلون ذلك
والأطباء يفعلون هذا وهكذا إذا كنت تختبر إذا كان
لديك عشرة فقط  مجموعات الاختبار في
المستشفى بالكامل ، ستأخذهم
إلى وحدة العناية المركزة وستقول هنا
هنا مرضاي المرضى ودعنا
نختبرهم وبالطبع سيكون معدل الوفيات
بين المرضى العشرة في وحدة العناية
المركزة مرتفعًا جدًا  مخيف جدًا ولكن بعد ذلك
إذا كان لديك تدفق مئات من
مجموعات الاختبار الجديدة ، فربما يمكنك الآن اختبار
المستشفى بالكامل وستلتقط بالفعل
العديد من الحالات ولكن
ليس الكثير من الوفيات لأن
هؤلاء الأشخاص بخير أو التقطوا هذا
الفيروس  ربما وليس لديك حتى
أعراض منه ، وبعد ذلك ربما
يكون لديك ألف مجموعة حتى تتمكن من
لمس الأصدقاء والجيران ، هذا ما
يفعلونه في كوريا الجنوبية وفي
الواقع هذا النوع مما فعلوه
أثناء الغوص  أميرة إذا كنت  nk حول
هذا الموضوع ، لقد اختبروا الجميع ، لذا فإن
الاختبار الواسع النطاق في مثل هذا الموقف
مهم للغاية وسببهم
هو حقًا أنه رقم واحد مزدوج ،
فهو يمنحنا أرقامًا أفضل
تعكس ما يحدث بالفعل والذي
قد يساعدنا في تقليل مخاوفنا
لأننا "  سنلتقط المزيد من الحالات
التي لم نكن نعرفها عن الأشخاص الذين
ليس لديهم أعراض أو أعراض خفيفة
وهذا أمر مهم حقًا لتقليل
مخاوفنا لجعل أنفسنا نشعر بالاطمئنان إلى
أن هذه ليست مشكلة
كبيرة للجميع وما زالوا  نفس
الرمز يساعدنا في التعرف على تلك الحالات
لنقول لهؤلاء الأفراد ، من فضلك إذا كان
لديك هذا الفيروس إذا أصبت
به ، فهؤلاء هم الأشخاص الذين
يحتاجون إلى العزلة عن كبار السن
، ولا أوصي إذا كنت مصابًا
بمرض  انتقل الآن إلى دار لرعاية المسنين
لأن هذا هو المكان الذي قد
تتسبب فيه بالفعل في حدوث مشكلة كما نراه في
واشنطن ، لذا فإن التباين بين
الأرقام يتعلق باستراتيجية الاختبار الخاصة بك
و  ct أننا في هذا
البلد في الواقع بشكل مفاجئ أو
غير مفاجئ ، لقد تم إلقاء القبض
علينا حقًا هنا رأينا هذا قادمًا ،
ومع ذلك لا توجد مجموعات اختبار كافية
متاحة
والتي لا يمكن الدفاع عنها ،
فنحن بحاجة بالفعل إلى مزيد من الاختبارات وهذا
ما فعلوه في كوريا الجنوبية بالمناسبة
مايكل وأرقامهم في الواقع
أفضل بكثير لديهم معدل وفيات 0.6٪
في كوريا الجنوبية لأنهم اختبروا
الكثير من الناس